Brand new Benjamins hit
the streets this week,
so what do all those little
symbols on your $100 bills
mean, anyway?
Hey, guys.
This is Annie for DNews.
Newly redesigned $100 bills
went into circulation this week,
though it might be a little
while before you actually
lay eyes on one.
Depending on how
often you actually
come into contact with $100
bills in general-- in my case,
never.
But you, maybe you're a
bank teller, say this guy.
In which case, you may
have already seen one.
Either way, when you
do, you'll notice
a number of changes
meant to enhance
the security of the bill.
Now as some background,
counterfeit US currency
is relatively rare.
In 2003, the US Department of
Treasury estimated $70 million
worth of counterfeit US cash
in circulation worldwide,
which actually only
accounts for about one
out of every 10,000 notes.
But it's not unheard of,
and hundreds are obviously
among the most valuable fakes.
You might remember
reports from several years
ago about so-called
super notes, which
were near-perfect $100
fakes that were once
rumored to come
from North Korea.
In the early 2000s,
a British gang
was charged with printing
millions of dollars
worth of high caliber
fakes as well.
So every few years, the US
adds new security features
to stay ahead of the curve.
And in this version,
there are two.
A blue 3D ribbon with
images of bells and 100s,
and a color-changing
bell in an inkwell.
Both are meant to
be user-friendly,
allowing average people to
easily verify that it's real.
Apart from those
two changes, there
are several design
updates that, as always,
incorporate bits of US
history and identity.
The biggest being the Benji
himself, Benjamin Franklin,
who happens to be one of two
non-US presidents whose mug
is on paper currency,
the other being Alexander
Hamilton on your 10 spots.
Hold the bill up to
light, and you'll
see a second Benjamin
on the right.
Other details include
tiny printed words
on his jacket collar and
phrases from the Declaration
of Independence to the
right of the portrait.
And on the front
and back, you'll
see gold 100s in large type
to help the visually impaired
recognize the bills.
Currency design in general
has attracted lots of intrigue
over the years,
the most persistent
of these having to do with
the symbol on the back of ones
and a vast Freemason or
Illuminati conspiracy,
depending on what
message board you're on.
This theory was so
persistent that it once
prompted an official rebuke
from the Freemasons of America.
Well, what all that detail
really comes down to
is making it as difficult
as possible to forge,
and maybe even nice to look at.
It's money, after all.
And for more on how money
makes the world go round,
be sure to check out
Trace's episode from a while
back on the real value
of paper currency.
Have you seen one of these
new bills out in the wild yet?
Let us know in the comments
or on Twitter @DNews.
As always, thanks for tuning
in, and I'll see you next time.